buenas tardes en general ha sido eso es
bastante dramática en la capital porque
no se informa informan siempre que es
peligroso a regresarse la capital
entonces algún ataque aéreo puede pasar
otra vez porque anoche y también el día
de ayer pasaron los los ataques con
misiles cruceros guiados para controlar
infraestructuras de la capital entonces
aquí seguimos con esa amenaza de generar
por cierto bueno justamente esta semana
pudimos ver en larguísimas filas de
automóviles retornando aquí efe después
de la retirada de los soldados rusos de
la zona y de los exteriores de kiev como
es la vida en este momento en la capital
con la gente que está regresando de la
gente está regresando por qué la gente
se quedaban aquí sus apartamentos sus
negocios sus hombres sus maridos
entonces la gente tiene motivación al
regresar pero el alcalde
y en forma para no hacerlo porque la
situación en que sigue
siendo difícil y peligroso por eso la
gente todavía debe quedarse en dos
partes occidentales de un año también en
el extranjero porque es
temprano para regresar a la capital por
eso bueno y ante esa situación de
dificultad y que es todavía muy pronto
para regresar además de los nuevos
ataques que se esperan pues alexander
como se están protegiendo qué medidas se
están tomando quienes permanecen en la
ciudad
la medida es la misma seguimos con un
toque de queda por ejemplo seguimos con
puestos de control con barricadas
muchísimas américas creo que el número
deseado aumentó durante los últimos días
pero la gente se gustó la gente
finalmente conoce las reglas de
seguridad y cómo cuidarse quieres ser
durante la sociedad hay que hacer
durante algún asalto aéreo ahora es no
es una sorpresa para nosotros porque en
los bombardeos ahora son nuestra vida
cotidiana como decir algún riesgo la
gente está preparada para y las
autoridades también siempre nos informan
con algunos también aplicaciones móviles
que hay que refugiarse inmediatamente
entonces la ciudad de nacional está
preparada lo que usted lo que debemos
realizar es que la guerra se continúa y
la capital es un objetivo central de
rusia por eso hay que hablar pues muchas
gracias a ustedes le deseo que continúe
con salud y seguridad dentro de lo
posible gracias al ex antes